[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue de salaire de
parlement hebdo va refaire l'actualité
politique et parlementaire bourgeois
catellier le dr bonjour nickel d'ânesse
est avec nous cette semaine malek boutih
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
socialiste de l'essonne soutien de
manuel valls
on va revenir avec vous sur trois thèmes
majeurs le premier débat de la primaire
à gauche qui a eu lieu les propositions
du candidat de la droite françois fillon
sur le thème de l'immigration et puis
cette semaine on a beaucoup parlé aussi
du non cumul des mandats mais évidemment
malek boutih on va commencer par parler
du débat les sept candidats de la gauche
ont donc débattu pendant un petit peu
plus de deux heures devant les caméras
avec cette question en tout cas vous
commencer par cela
quels mots pour qualifier le bilan de
françois hollande propose de les écouter
difficile à défendre
comment faire peut mieux faire d'un
bilan contrasté en demi-teinte
incompréhension qui s'est établie très
vite avec le payer avec ceux qui nous
avaient soutenus
mon sentiment le plus profond c'est un
sentiment d'inachevé comme si nous
étions restés sur beaucoup de sujets au
milieu du gué bilan qu'il convient de
porter parce que beaucoup de réformes
pour redresser le pays ont été
entreprises vertes et d'avoir servi les
français dans une période très difficile
notamment nous l'oublions jamais face au
terrorisme
malek boutih qu'elle vous vous employez
pour qualifier le bilan de françois
hollande ou à ben moi je suis pas au
débat 17 camps bay mais quand même j'ai
pas répondre à cette question
simplement je remarque que j'ai trouvé
beaucoup de flottement chez beaucoup de
candidats qui arrivait pas à trouver
on l'a bien vu dans leur qualificatif y
chercher des sortes de nuances entre
nauze en il rejeter ni l'accepter il
était sentiment d'être mal à l'aise par
rapport à ce bilan tout bilan de toutes
façons et nuancé c'est pas ce n'est pas
le débat mais est un moment la politique
est un moment vous devez dire ce que
vous pensez et j'ai apprécié que manuel
valls est assumé parce que je pense que
l'on appelle vous êtes un soutien oui
bien sûr mais on en avait déjà discuté
mais moi je pense que c'est une élection
présidentielle ne se joue pas sur le
bilan
compte les ailes ce qui s'est passé
durant le quinquennat va peser c'est
indéniable mais je pense que on est
tellement en train de changer d'époque
regarder comment cette présidentielle ne
ressemble en rien à loudes donc je
préfère sur le bilan qu'on ait une
position nette qu'on assume le mauvais
comme le bon et que l'avenir soit en
percer quand vous parliez de flottement
ça veut dire quoi j'ai trouvé que chez
les autres candidats
il avait une manière de 2011 il sema
beaucoup marqué nuance est exaucé arrêté
citer un exemple
ah ben je dirais que sincèrement orbi
sylvia pinel et manuel valls qui ont
assumé les autres n'étaient pas dans le
contre il aurait dû dire bah je trouve
le bilan mauvais où je le trouve que la
part du bon et nenê négatif mais sont
restés dans une sorte de zone où
finalement il savait pas trop bien
s'il fallait dès le début se positionner
d'ailleurs ça c'est suivi dans le temps
et dans le reste du débat où j'ai vu que
beaucoup de candidats avait un problème
de positionnement let
donc pour vous c'est un sentiment de
flottement sur toute la durée du débat
pour les autres candidats mais à part
manuel valls y au compromis
non non je trouve que sur des points
précis de programme
il avait des certitudes cette échelle je
le conteste pas mais ce qui m'a semblé
c'est que ce qui démarque est manuel
valls et des autres candidats c'est pas
sur les propositions contrairement à ce
que certains biens pas sûrs il n'a pas
de manuel stature nom et une défense du
bilan est une des vraies en vidéo cela
quoi d'une cohérence politique c'est à
dire une position politique ou en fait
c'est pas à chaque question sa réponse
mais une vision où les questions
s'intègre dans cette vision il a une
cohérence
on est d'accord on n'est pas d'accord
mais il ya quelques c'était je trouve
solide et construit alors que j'ai
trouvé chez les autres on voyait bien
une tentative d'essayer parfois d'avoir
le beurre et l'argent solide et
construit mais suffisant pour surclasser
ses autres concurrents pour ce premier
tour il faut pas se tromper dans ce type
de compétition je mets des guillemets il
s'agit pas de surclasser il faut pas
faire un coup médiatique s'agit pas de
briller un soir il s'agit de de dégager
une majorité nette pour la primaire
c'est le premier objectif de manuel
valls
et donc il ne faut pas juger à chaque
étape
c'est pas encore gagné d'abord c'est pas
encore gagné mais surtout ce n'est pas
encore l'élection présidentielle antivol
dont vous parliez est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que ce débat ait réussi 3 8
millions de téléspectateurs c'est 2
millions de moins que pour le débat de
la droite sur la même chaîne de
télévision réussit ou pas oui moi je
pense moi même à 3,8 millions on a quand
même une audience extrêmement
respectable vous êtes des professionnels
des médias vous savez très bien qu'une
émission qui commence à 21h qui finit à
23h30 au mois de janvier
c'est pas très facile surtout qui a déjà
eu les débats la droite et parfois ce
sont les mêmes gens qui regardent les de
débarras mais rassure je suis pour vous
oui je pense que ça ça ça ouvre une
perspective positive pour la primaire
absolument alors revenons sur l'un des
thèmes abordés la politique économique
et notamment la loi travaille beaucoup
de candidats qu'on a deux candidats
c'est à dire qu'on a entendu veulent
abroger cette loi votée il ya quelques
mois par le mans manuel valls l'a
défendu écouter cet extrait j'entends
évoqué l'idée même d'abrogation ici
parmi les candidats nous voulons abrogé
quoi nous voulons abrogé quoi la
négociation dans l'entreprise
soutenu par les syndicats réformistes le
compte personnel d'activité je le disais
tout à l'heure qui se met en oeuvre le
comte pénibilité parce qu'il ya des
salariés qui travaillent dur il te vois
qu'ils doivent pouvoir partir plus tôt à
la retraite ce sont des droits nouveaux
pour les salariés il y à des
dispositions dans la loi quelques mots i
qui facilite le licenciement et qui vont
fragiliser les salariés au moment où il
cherche à préserver leur emploi c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles je veut
abroger cette loi j'abrogerai la loi
elle comrie qu'elle pose d'énormes
problèmes d'abord dans sa naissance à
genève donc il est absolument impossible
de faire une loi pour 29 millions de
salariés sans discuter avec les
représentants des dix salariés dans les
syndicats et les représentants des
salariés au parlement alors voilà sur
cette loi votée au parlement comme sur
d'autres sujets de politique économique
il y à bien deux visions de la société
deux approches des divergences
économiques profondes
c'est irréconciliables non non je fais
bien que et à la presse veut à tout prix
que ce mot irréconciliables reviennent
dans le débat mais c'est pas loin en
tout cas il ya deux approches deux connu
il ya deux saisons les deux approches
parce que j'écoute bien moi les propos
et pas les postures un papa la musique
il ya un premier ministre qui assume un
compromis pour faire évoluer le marché
du travail et pour trouver et on s'est
tous en france
je vous rappelle que le problème du
chômage de masse en france il existe
depuis 30 ans quelles que soient les
situations et les conjonctures
économiques même dans les meilleures
confitures il même si lui un reflux on a
un problème sur le marché de l'emploi
donc on doit le faire évoluer de l'autre
côté j'entends quoi j'entends des gens
qui disent qu'ils vont abrogé mais ce
qui était intéressant c'est qu'ils ont
été dans l'incapacité de dire voilà quel
autre type c'est à dire ils sont dans un
statu quo or si la gauche reste dans son
statut qu elle elle sera minoritaire
dans le pays
elle n'a aucune chance de gagner on est
obligés nous d'être une gauche qui
retrouve auprès de l'opinion publique et
en particulier de son électorat
une certaine idée que j'appelle la
prospérité c'est à dire que honda on
doit retrouver du crédit sur l'économie
voilà mais pas sur le revenu universel
ce que propose benoît hamon alors que
manuel valls dit que c'est la société du
farniente de l'assistanat
ça ce sont également deux visions c'est
une proposition de benoît hamon pouvez
pas dire qu'il ait pas de propositions
j'ai pas dit qui avait pas de
propositions je dis simplement que ce
découpage d'abord il ya deux blocs
c'est ce que je constate dans ce débat
il ya la position de manuel valls et les
autres positions et les autres positions
vous mettez que vous mettez dans le même
à peu près à nice il ya des petites
nuances tactiques ou d'aménagement mais
qui sont qu'est la gauche
je dirais d'un certain point de vue
c'est ça qui est frappant puisqu'on
parlait du bilan avant de françois
hollande c'est quand même une gauche qui
ressemble à françois hollande les autres
c'est-à-dire une gauche qui dit ni oui
ni non
une gauche qui dit qu' il faudrait un
peu de justice mais un peu de souplesse
une gauche qui dit il faudrait un peu de
ceci un peu cela c'est will bush ne
tranche pas qui ne tranche pas une
gauche qui n'a qui n'est pas capable de
dire je prends une décision je l'assumé
et on verra bien et qui se posent en
direction politique c'est la gauche qui
hésite
excusez moi ça veut dire que la gauche
de manuel valls est pas la gauche de
françois hollande
pas exactement la même c'est clair c'est
historique c'est pas ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui il ya ça n'a aucun rapport
avec la manière dont ils ont gouverné
ensemble avec même si les comptables du
bilan d'un bilan commun quand vous êtes
dans une équipe et je vous rappelle
qu'hier vous aviez cru des gens qui
étaient tous temps gouvernement tout
cela par navacelles anti-hollande non
j'ai pas dis que c'est l anti hollande
je dis que c'est autre chose que
françois hollande n'est pas pareil mais
si vous pouvez préciser ça dit c'est
autre chose c'est autre chose c'est à
dire c'est la volonté de faire avancer
une vision politique avec une cohérence
avec une dynamique est pas de trouver en
permanence d équilibre et je trouve que
le moment d'ailleurs qu'ils étaient plus
révélateur c'est pas sur l'économie
c'est évidemment la question qui a été
posée sur le fameux débat sur la
nationalité par rapport aux terroristes
et c'est là où on a vu de la très
clairement une position de manuel valls
assumer nette et claire sur son identité
politique et ce qu'ils pensaient en
matière de sécurité
pas de sécurité je trouve que chez les
hôtes ya une recherche d' équilibre en
permanence alors que chez manuel valls
il ya une recherche
je dirais d'avancé après il ay et c'est
normal tout le monde ne va pas être
d'accord mais une chose est sûre c'est
cohérent on sait ce qu'il veut on sait
quels sont les contours de sa vision
politique et on sait qu'ils l'assument
chez les autres je trouve une continuité
de ce que j'entends depuis plusieurs
années et au parti socialiste et quand
on a été au gouvernement c'est à dire
oui la pluie c'est important mais il
faut aussi un peu de soleil et un peu de
grêle et un peu de nuages
bon évidemment si on peut tout avoir ce
serait formidable
alors on va parler malek boutih à
présent de françois fillon qui était
cette semaine à nice et menton pour
parler immigration
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le candidat de la droite a tenu une
réunion publique dans les alpes
maritimes il veut combattre
l'immigration illégale et réduire
l'immigration légale au strict minimum
stéphanie des pierres et vianney laurent
l'ont suivi françois fillon arrive au
poste frontière de menton entre l'italie
et la france
un lieu symbolique pour parler
immigration et sécurité depuis les
attentats les contrôles routiers sont
renforcés en contre-haut une voie ferrée
parfois emprunté à pied par les migrants
on a eu pendant très longtemps des
tentatives de franchissement de la
frontière à pied par le vecteur
ferroviaire d'où le dispositif qu'on a
mis en place pour contrôler aussi cet
endroit avec donc des gendarmes mobiles
pour lutter contre l'immigration
illégale françois fillon veut réformer
schengen et en attendant renforcer les
frontières françaises
quelques habitants de la région qui
aident les migrants sont venus montrer
leur désaccord
derrière tout ça il ya des gens qui
souffrent il ya des enfants qui sont
morts et à cinq gamins qui sont morts
sur le 4 sur l'autoroute ans rejoint de
fer en tentant de passer ce frontières
le soir en meeting à nice sur ses
anciennes terres très sarkozyste
françois fillon déroule son programme
toujours radical la france doit non
seulement lutter contre l'immigration
illégale
mais elle doit aussi réduire son
immigration légale au strict minimum
la délivrance de visas et titre de
séjour n'a pas cessé de dérivés ces
dernières années le nombre de visas
accordés en 2015 a augmenté de 40% par
rapport à 2012 pour reprendre les choses
en main je veux que le parlement puisse
adopter chaque année un quota limitant
le nombre d'étrangers qui pourront être
admis en france en fonction de nos
besoins économiques et nos capacités
d'intégration en parlant d'immigration
il espérait faire oublier la polémique
sur la sécurité sociale mais elle
revient dans la bouche de christian
estrosi qui affirme que le mot social
n'est pas une grossièreté moins critique
les militants eux se sont convertis
c'est la parole qu'on attendait depuis
longtemps
j'ai été sarkozyste et maintenant je
suis à derrière fillon moi j'ai soutenu
nicolas sarkozy lors de la primaire mais
on a obéi aux ordres de nicolas sarkozy
et quand il nous a demandé de nous
rallier à françois fillon on l'a fait et
aujourd'hui on est uni derrière françois
fillon après les alpes-maritimes
françois fillon sera devant le parti
samedi pour le conseil national
alors immigration minimale contrôlée
côtes à l'immigration selon françois
fillon ça vous inspire quoi
un feuilleton que je vois depuis que je
suis enfant quasiment c'est-à-dire
élections présidentielles débat sur
l'immigration y en aura - plus quotas
machin sa cible bien sûr j'ai moi-même
commis il ya plus de dix ans un rapport
sur comment la france ne devait se doter
d'une politique d'immigration puisqu'il
faut savoir que notre pays n'a pas de
politique d'immigration nous avons une
réglementation mais pas de politique
donc ce sera un débat qui aura lieu au
moment de la présidentielle mais il
ferait une erreur
françois fillon et la droite ferait une
erreur en pensant que ce sujet est un
sujet qui peut être utilisé comme dans
les autres présidentielle un sujet qui
qui qui polémiquent un sujet qui lui
donne de la force pourquoi parce que je
pense que l'opinion publique sur ces
sujets là a considérablement évolué elle
est devenue moins sensibles aux envolées
lyriques et elle demande beaucoup plus
de concret il va falloir être costaud
par exemple quand on parle du marché du
travail
françois fillon sait est très soutenu
par les milieux de l'entreprise
1 ce n'est pas une surprise les milieux
de l'entreprise sont très demandeurs de
la main d'oeuvre étrangère
c'est eux qui ce qu'ils font les appels
on l'a vu avec elle la circulaire ans à
qui on propose aussi de fixer des quotas
votée par le parlement vous seriez prêt
vous votez de toute façon quand on sera
parlementaire et si je suis
parlementaire on verra bien ce qui se
passe mais moi je pense que par exemple
si le débat devait s'ouvrir
je pense que plutôt que met en avant les
enjeux économiques et sociaux même si le
marché du travail est un enjeu
la première question c'est la question
des valeurs si on doit faire une
politique d'immigration
c'est d'abord avec des gens qui ont
envie de vivre en france et qui adhèrent
à la laïcité un autre modèle de vie et
qui respecte le droit des femmes moi mon
moi c'est la question numéro 1 je
préfère avoir un étranger sans
qualification qui est qui adhèrent aux
valeurs de la france
un ingénieur qui arrivent ici avec des
diplômes et qui en fait est tous là au
sénat donc deux visions de la france que
vous allez mettre en perspective
évidemment ce n'est pas en vérité en
vérité de débat sur l'immigration si on
est objectif politiquement il va être
intégré à tous l'ensemble du débat qui
est lié avec le terrorisme la guerre
nous la laïcité mais la laïcité on avait
questionné sur ce thème par exemple lors
de ce débat c'est tout le problème de
débats qui sont très tranchés comme ça
avec très peu de temps mais comment ces
centrales je pense que c'est une
question centrale
je pense que si notre pays en difficulté
ce n'est pas et c'est pour ça toutes les
analyses techniques elle je dis pas
qu'elles ne valent rien mais il ya un
problème de structure de vision de ce
qu'est la france maintenant du 21e
siècle et donc je pense que par exemple
dans l'immigration les questions de
valeurs sont supérieurs aux enjeux
policiers pour l'instant pourquoi parce
que le limitera il faut un contrôle mais
là où je pense que la france a mal agi
où elle a fait des erreurs
c'est pas une question de très mal
traités au bien traités c'est que en
mettant en avant autour du concept
d'immigration choisie
les diplômés elle s'est pas rendu compte
que le diplôme c'est bien mais moi si
c'est pour me taper un ingénieur
islamiste en france je suis pas d'accord
je préfère un ouvrier un culte mais qui
à dornes pays et qui dit qui est ici ils
profitent de la liberté
la question des valeurs à mon avis pour
les français est supérieur aux zones
sans jeu avec ce genre de proposition
est-ce que vous estimez que la laïcité
est en danger que françois fillon met en
danger cette laïcité ou pas on verra
assez comme ça ça béton au rebond mais
c'est pas le c'est la laïcité elle est
sincèrement le danger numéro 1 sur la
laïcité c'est les enfants les offensives
aujourd'hui d'un certain nombre de
religions d'un certain nombre de
radicalité dans les religions c'est là
où le grand danger sur la leis
radicalité où vous avez commis un
rapport là aussi c'est en juillet 2015
génération radical radicalisation de la
jeunesse
qu'est ce qu'il en est resté de ce
rapport françois hollande ne vous a
jamais jamais fait appel à vos
propositions
bungle grèce ne doit pas sensé pas saisi
non plus c'est pas vrai sommes nous
alors si nous sommes juste je
supporterai pas et je serai pas derrière
manuel valls dans une cocotte c'est
aussi pour ça que vous soutenez
d'ailleurs safer par celui des thèmes
oui vous savez mais je ne suis pas un
balle 6 et manuel valls ne regroupe pas
autour de lui des groupies ils demandent
pas dans cette primaire à ce qu'on soit
d'accord avec tout ce qu'il a fait dans
sa vie
mais j'ai constaté que il avait une
volonté que je ne trouvais pas ailleurs
non seulement il m'a permis librement de
faire ce rapport de dire des choses
qu'on n'avait pas le droit de dire dans
les autres riders pas plus chez vous et
notamment chez les socialistes bien sûr
chez un certain nombre il y en a qui est
acquis qu'ils étaient d'accord et et et
troisièmement il a été utile puisque il
a aujourd'hui pour les services de
renseignement pour les pour ceux qui
luttent contre le terrorisme mais aussi
dans un certain nombre de ministères
donc il ya eu un travail c'est pas un
truc qui est fait pour flamber et monter
des coups un rapport comme ça c'est
vraiment un travail de fond la sécurité
des français
c'est pour moi en tout cas j'ai pas fait
ce rapport pour avoir une médaille je
les fais juste pour aider ceux qui se
battent contre le terrorisme justement
par rapport à ce rapport cette semaine
marine le pen a dit de vous il est pas
socialiste lui vous avez été mis dans un
tiroir elle va vous en sortirez pour
demain et nous toujours un peu dangereux
quand marine le pen veut vous sortir de
quelque chose de tiroir non je rigole je
pense que sincèrement sur ces sujets à
un problème de compétence allez c'est
une c'est une femme qui a qui est très
forte dans la communication qui sait
peser dans les débats publics
mais je pense qu'en matière de sécurité
en vue depuis que les attentats
terroristes
je suis frappé par l'absence de 2,2 de
compétences et une incompréhension de ce
qui est en train de se passer le front
national la vérité est dépassée par
l'accélération de l'histoire et elle
court après alors je veux bien qu alice
moura porte parce que ce n'est pas
interdit de le lire république qu'elle
puisse même s'en inspire et pourquoi pas
parce que moi je vous dire une chose
j'ai fait ce rapport pour la france pas
pour un parti on passe à un autre sujet
je vous le mets à malek boutih cette
semaine on a aussi beaucoup parlé de
l'assemblée du sénat et notamment des
parlementaires du cumul des mandats
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et cette question du non-cumul des
mandats françois fillon la tranchée on
ne touchera pas à qu'il dise s'il
devient président de la république bien
entendu et le président du sénat gérard
larcher l'a confirmé lors d'une
conférence de presse propos de l'écouter
il ya quelque chose d'un peu inévitable
il est vrai dans le texte qui a été
proposé par les socialistes
faut bien le dire je vais pas voter j'ai
combattu c'est que vous pouvez être mère
dutarte godrans dans les yvelines 46
habitants et il est impossible à ce
moment là d'être sénateur mais vous
pouvez présidé la deuxième métropole de
france et pouvoir cumuler l'ensemble
mais tout ça c'est la raison qu'il
faudra retrouver mais c'est claire nette
et tranchée par françois fillon
en ce qui concerne l'immédiateté ce sera
pas le projet numéro un du français
qu'ils attendent qu'on en reparle
travail emploi sécurité donc pas une
priorité en tout cas ce qui pourrait un
jour arriver c'est un référendum vous
remettrez de dans les institutions et
puis que faire des parlementaires du
nombre de parlementaires éventuellement
le non cumul des mandats ce serait la
bonne solution ça le référendum ou
carrément au vernet parents de danse
vous dire une chose je sais que c'est
hyper à la mode tout le monde et pour le
référendum
j'ai même entendu benoît hamon hier
défendent comme étant la voix du peuple
ben moi je fais partie peut-être des
rares politiques encore quel courage de
dire que c'est pas vrai que parfois
quand on met au vote des choses selon
des circonstances selon des passions
selon des fièvres des gens peuvent
prendre des décisions qui sont
contraires à l'intérêt de leur pays et
même à leur propre intérêt tout vous ne
seriez pas pour le référendum jeu en
tout cas pas automatiquement qu'un
référendum sur un changement de la
constitution
ça me semble obligatoire puisque c'est
la règle de la vie démocratique mais
vous savez le cumul des mandats bon bah
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à droite il ya
lui ils sont fait arnaquer et c'est une
arnaque était qu'on a vu il a fait le
tour des popotes fillon il aura dit bhl
sur j'aime bien voulu entendre
d'ailleurs ses réponses étaient plus
nuancées que ce qu'on dit chacun est
inclus entente qui voulaient en disant
oh là là on va retrouver notre cumul
mais en fait ce genre de réformes
démocratiques
on ne revient jamais en arrière il n'y
aura jamais de retour sur le cumul des
mandats et il va y avoir dans les années
à venir un changement profond du
personnel politique en france
je prends le pari que dans une ou deux
législatures les femmes sont
majoritaires à l'assemblée grâce à ce
système et ceux de ce nombre le non
cumul c'est donc ça fait partie de
l'histoire pour vous la france ira vers
ça et le visage de l'assemblée nationale
s'en trouvera complètement changé de
l'assemblée comme il a déjà
considérablement changé dans les
territoires avec les lois sur la parité
ça va aller jusqu'en haut ça ouvre même
la perspective qu'un jour notre pays
soit dirigé par une femme
en tout cas moi je l'espère et je pense
que il n'y aura jamais de retour en
arrière sur cette réforme
et bien je vous propose à présent dans
les boutiques d'accueillir notre
partenaire du figaro.fr qui est allé jim
jarrassé qui va des corps telle
actualité politique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour jim c'est à vous bonjour katia
montfort mondiale bonjour malek boutih
on va revenir si vous le souhaitez sur
la campagne de manuel valls que que vous
soutenez on a l'impression qu'elle peine
un peu à décoller cette campagne cette
semaine il s'en est pris aux
journalistes qui dit il pose toujours
les mêmes questions alors on pense
peut-être au 49 3 c'est à ces questions
aux revirements sur sa position sur la
loi travail est-ce que c'est pas un peu
un signe de fébrilité quand on commence
à avoir à s'en prendre au système
médiatique comme il dit je vous dire une
chose il me semble que ça fait quasiment
un mois jour pour jour que manuel valls
a annoncé sa candidature et je serai
prêt vraiment à prendre le pari que si
on fait une étude objectifs qu'on livre
aurait un institut d'étude des articles
sortie des commentaires de ce qui est
publié sur internet il est le candidat
qui en prend le plus dans la tête et y
compris de médium d'une cabale médias
dès maintenant pas du tout ce que vous
excluez fêteront pas du tout je suis pas
je suis pas parano et je crois pas aux
théories du complot même dans des
journaux où il était un chouchou quinze
jours avant il est devenu un diable pour
loi mais parce que en fait je vous dire
une chose la vérité c'est où toutes les
forces sociales économiques politiques
les candidats
tout le monde était parti dans une
présidentielle avec françois hollande
qui représenterait le parti social et
c'est ça la vérité et je me souviens
mois de beaucoup de journalistes me
disait encore malek c'est bien de dire
que tu veux pas de françois hollande
mais ça n'arrivera jamais il sait il
change la donne y bouscule et donc il a
une pression qui est en partie normale
parce qu'il faut subir cette pression et
de l'autre côté il a par contre une
remarque est juste je suis prêt à
prendre le pari que la moitié des
journalistes qui parlent du 49-3 ne
savent même pas ce que c'est vraiment
quand on parle donc pour faire attention
on parle aux français dans la rue de
manuel valls est la première chose qui
revient dans la bouche il le 49-3 les
jets de farine à strasbourg ce n'est pas
une ambiance je vais vous dire quelque
chose j'en arrive à vous dire quelque
chose je le saurais si les journalistes
parler aux gens dans la rue je serais
vraiment au courant
donc je crois que c'est pas très vrai
voilà est ce que est ce que vous quand
même vous le reconnaissez dans cette
campagne manuel valls en parlais tout à
l'heure des questions de laïcité
on a l'impression qu'il a mis sous
couvercle ces questions là que qui les
abordent - est-ce que est-ce que vous
avez sentiment également est-ce que vous
reconnaissez votre candidat je dis pas
que il est parfait dans sa campagne
je ne dis pas qu'il n'a pas commis des
fautes de carre ici ou là mais ça par
exemple non non elle a hésité est au
contraire un des points forts sont à qui
soient forts de sa campagne hier
d'ailleurs il l'a mis là il n'a marqué
mais c'est la particularité de ces
débats là on en aura deux autres donc on
verra bien mais oui c'est pas un axe
fort c'est même autre chose c'est son
identité politique c'est ce qui même le
démarque parce que danse dans la vision
qu'il a la gauche française doit se
reconstruire d'abord sur un socle de
valeurs solides c'est bien beau de
parler des mais elle est divisée sur ce
thème là précisément il ya quand même
des divisions à cac40 on verra moi j'ai
remarqué une chose sur la laïcité
il ya beaucoup de divisions dans des
déclarations au off mais dans les débats
où il faut face aux français on tremble
moi je pense que la ligne de manuel
valls sur la laïcité est une ligne qui
nous permet de reconstruire la gauche
parce que il sait moi j'ai toujours dit
la chose suivante et revancharde
c'est pas ça le problème moi déjà mois
pour moi je mets jamais d'adjectifs
derrière laïcité c'est une manière de la
détruire
pour moi la chose avec des propos tenus
sur un rush valu le maquereau est
historiquement historiquement la gauche
a toujours été brisée sur des débats de
grande valeur pas sur les débats
économiques souvent dit à la gauche a
trahi truc le social l'économique mais
en vérité regarder l'histoire du parti
socialiste quand est ce qu'il a été
défini en difficulté le pacifisme de la
fin des années 30 la guerre d'algérie
c'est les grandes valeurs qui
structurent l'histoire de la gauche de
ce point de vue là attention la primaire
de la droite et la primaire de la gauche
sont différentes
pourquoi parce que la primaire de la
droite s'est fait autour d'un programme
je dirais économique et social
et très très fort alors que celle à
gauche il ya aussi une interrogation sur
sa propre identité
il ya la recherche aussi d'un leader pas
simplement d'un programme sur la
campagne de manuel valls
il a reçu le soutien de bon nombre de
demi du gouvernement mais ils se
bousculent pas quand même pour venir sur
le terrain dans les meetings le saunier
à ce que vous regrettez que les
ministres prennent pas plus clairement
position dans cette campagne
franchement je pense que ça ne
rajouterai pas grand-chose grand chose
ceux qui veulent marquer leur engagement
le fond et puis sincèrement ce serait
quand même une grosse grosse foot que le
gouvernement se mette à faire campagne
au lieu de travail et donc dont j'ai
confiance je leur dis dressé dans
d'autres qua non non je dis que s'ils
ont une heure libre serait bien qu'ils
s'expriment en faveur de manuel valls et
j'en profite pas on a pu bien mais c'est
pas essentiels y en a une qui fait une
discorde campagne c'est ségolène royal
en faveur de d'emmanuel macro est ce que
ça vous dérange
sincèrement je vais vous dire ce que
j'en pense je trouve ça pathétique
pourquoi je dis pathétique parce que
c'est une femme pauvre pour qui j'ai eu
beaucoup de respect je trouve que
l'histoire de cette femme elle est très
révélatrice de la manière dont les
femmes peuvent subir des choses en
politique
incroyables qu'aucun homme n'a jamais
vécu et elle n'est pas à la hauteur de
ses qualités
c'est dommage finir comme ça avec des
petites phrases revanchard en attendant
son poste à l'onu c'est pas terrible
oui oui parce que qui se dirigeait vers
un traitement c'est son soutien c'est le
fait qu'elle ait changé d'avis sur
emmanuel macron dents mais quand on fait
la politique font faire elle a été
candidate à la primaire elle était
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
elle a qu'à dire ce qu'elle pense
jusqu'au bout si elle est en désaccord
halak à dire pourquoi halak a développé
une ligne
et si elle veut soutenir emmanuel macron
c'est son problème mais laquelle faire
mais les pas de deux feutré de la petite
bourgeoisie socialiste sur le thème on
aime on n'aime pas ils ont rejoint vite
socialiste oui ça existe bien sûr vous
êtes agacé set cette semaine nous at-on
dit lors d'une réunion de groupe ps à
l'assemblée contre christophe castaner
qui soutient justement et manu emmanuel
maintenant et qu'ils voulaient poser une
question au nom du parti socialiste
est-ce que les soutiens de macron
doivent être exclu du ps selon vous
écoutez la moi je suis pas quelqu'un qui
exclue mais entre exclure et faire
mettre sur scène et valoriser ce qui
on le beurre et l'argent du beurre c'est
à dire son parti socialiste pour avoir
des investitures
mais ont mis une pièce sur macron cas où
ça tournerait mal il ya un problème
moi j'aime pas les gens qui chevauche de
chevaux en même temps j'aime pas les
opportunistes donc je papa de castetner
là sur le coup puisque c'est pas lui qui
met en cause je mets en cause le
président du groupe socialiste qui lui
n'est pas capable olivier faure n'est
pas capable de comprendre que c'est sa
responsabilité de garder une unité et
que c'est pas le moment d'introduire
avec un petite pointe de vis ce genre de
débats au sein du groupe social il ya
une question qui a été abordé lors du
débat hier c'est quelle attitude pour
les candidats qui va être sortir de la
primaire si jamais manuel macron se
maintient à un niveau en troisième
position et que le candidat 8 ps est en
quatrième position rôle ce coup
qu'est-ce qui va falloir faire danser
dans ces cas là est ce qu'il faudra
maintenir à tout prix la candidature du
ps avait une chose si on ne peut pas
l'élection présidentielle n'a pas
commencé ce qui nous donne déjà les
scores qui est arrivé en premier
deuxième troisième tout ça n'existe mans
vous voyez par un gros step by step
personnellement non je le vois pas oui
mais non je pense aux critiques il est
sympa c'est pas ça c'est que je pense
que l'élection présidentielle à la
différence de beaucoup d'autres
élections est une épreuve de vérité
impitoyable vous dites aujourd'hui
jamais moi malek boutih je ne me
rallierai à emmanuel macron quel que
soit le métier consiste potez les
circonstances vous pouvez demander aussi
si je quitte la vie politique n'en est
pas là c'est des questions
la police c'est dur au quotidien pour
pas parler de ce qui va se passer dans
trois quatre mois mais une chose est
sûre j'ai toujours été quelqu'un de
responsable
je suis un démocrate je suis un
républicain moi j'ai pas de haine contre
des gens je fais des analyses je propose
mes analyses et je suis franche et bien
merci pour cette franche exprès sur
malek boutih
allez on se ressemble à son prochaine
bonne semaine à tous
[Musique]